esperaron horas durante la noche para
tener la oportunidad de decirle adiós a
su ídolo
jean-paul belmondo
frente a su ataúd en el museo de los
inválidos en parís los seguidores
rindieron homenaje al actor
es un mito es una leyenda es más que
normal haber venido
gente de todas las edades esperaron en
fila las películas de belmont impactaron
a distintas generaciones ayudando a
definir la identidad francesa durante
seis décadas lleva tú
cinematográficamente y culturalmente si
es parte de la familia de las películas
de belmont eran las que veías un domingo
por la noche en la televisión cuando
salía con mi familia veíamos todas las
películas
personalmente veía todas desde que tengo
12 años no me perdió es parte de la
familia igual como la torre eiffel y el
monstruo misión inicial del mont recibió
honores estatales en una emotiva
ceremonia el presidente manuel macrón
describió a la estrella de cine como un
amigo que todos hubieran soñado tener
diciendo que con su muerte francia
perdió una parte de sí misma
[Aplausos]